I read in the garden a few years ago
that the average attention span for
human was 8 seconds what they did is
they got people in the room they gave
them tasks and they would throw
distractions their way to see how long
it would take before they would stop
doing the task and focus on the
distraction and they found that average
to be eight seconds what was more
interesting was the fact that the
average attention span for goldfish was
nine seconds so that tells us two things
on the one hand is if our attention span
is that short how do we manage our own
attention and focus secondly how do we
get the attention from other people
whether that is customers audiences that
we're looking to speak to and that's
where some of these things come in handy
the psychology of an audience how do we
engage with people so they want to
listen so they want to ask questions
they want to be curious